chester bennington has been laid to rest  [Music]  the late Lincoln Park frontman who took  his own life earlier this month was laid  to rest in a private funeral at the  south coast Botanic Garden near his home  in Palace Verdes on Saturday according  to TMZ a full stage including a drum kit  was set up for musical tributes during  the funeral jester's friend Austin  Carlile former lead singer of the band  of mice and men posted this  heartbreaking photo of the tour style  passes and pamphlets given out during  the memoriam Austin wrote in the caption  the service was beautiful and thanked  Linkin Park and Chester for quote  everything musician black bear also  shared his mementos from the funeral on  Twitter writing a little piece of you  has and will be in every song I sing on  stage forever  [Music]